everyone this is kevin from the chess
website calm one of the most requested
videos i get asked all the time is to
make some in depth some very very
thorough videos on some of the most
popular variations in some of the more
popular opening so the Sicilian defense
different variations the nazarov the
dragon is seller red dragon the
classical different things for the
Queen's Gambit the Queen's Gambit some
very very in-depth videos on different
variations so that's exactly what we're
going to do I think it's going to be a
great series I probably have about 80 or
so videos in the works for all the
different variations but we're actually
going to start with the Sicilian defense
and in this video we're going to start
with the dragon it is the sharpest it is
the most aggressive opening and being a
aggressive player myself it is my
favorite variation in the Sicilian
defense so I thought what better way to
start the series then with the dragon
variation so we'll go ahead and get into
the dragon variation that starts with
pawn to e4 pawn c5 this is the Sicilian
defense Knight f3 simple development
pawn to d6 pawn on d4 Black's going to
exchange his pawns on d4 Knight takes on
d4 black comes to f6 Knight c3 and pawn
to GC six now if you're watching this
and you're like hey Kevin you're going
through these moves really fast why are
you doing that again this is just the
dragon variation video if you do kind of
want to overview on the Sicilian defense
definitely watch that video first but
this right here is the dragon variation
so this is kind of going to where we're
spend a lot of time now there are four
different main lines that are going to
come out of this we do have yugoslavia
TAC which is very very common kind of
the main line that you'll see we do have
the classical variation we do have the
Lebanon fish variation it's my personal
favorite it's kind of the most
aggressive and lastly we do have the
harrington Gluck variation but these all
come from and stem from this setup right
here this is the dragon variation in the
Sicilian defense now as in most of my
videos I always say one of the more
important things you need to do when you
watch the video is try to understand the
theory behind it kind of the key
concepts that both sides are really
aiming for
that way you're not really memorizing
moves and if you get into a chess game
and someone does move exactly as you
expect them to as doesn't move exactly
they did in the video you can't
understand the theory in your game
playing behind it so you kind of know
how to move forward with that so before
we kind of get into the main line and
the main variations within the dragon
variation of the Sicilian offense I do
want to kind of talk about some of the
key objectives for both sides and kind
of what they're looking for in this game
plan now keep in mind it is White's move
so white can obviously he can develop
another one of his minor pieces as you
can see he has a huge lead in
development especially in the center of
the board here if he he could you know
move another pawn to f4 he could really
try to dominate the center of the board
he already is kind of dominating the
board he could develop another minor
piece black only has one minor piece
right here on the f6 square so as far as
development black is definitely behind
so white really wants to take advantage
of his lead in development white is also
really trying to hone down on these
light squares obviously he does have
this pawn here on e4 he does have a
weakness he doesn't have both of his
center pawns so while black does have
both his e pawn and his deep on white
does not but his pawn here on e4 is very
very powerful and it does hold down this
f5 and this d5 square both of the light
squares on the center of the board which
are very very important now if we look
at black hair black does have a few
options obviously he eventually wants to
bring his Bishop to g7 he really wants
to hone down on this long diagonal here
he wants to kind of key in on this dark
squares in the turn of the board he
already has this pawn here on d6 if he
wanted to he could obviously start to
push forward with his pawn to e6 or d5
later on into the game he does have to
be very very cautious because if he does
move this pawn forward to let's say e5
he will have a backward pawn here on d6
so something to keep in back your mind
when you are playing as black now from
his light square bishop here on a c8 he
does want to give this involved into the
game he does have his night here on b8
right now it typically is going to come
to CC
trying to control the center of the
board he does have this C file it is a
semi open semi file
more than likely his rooks going to come
to this semi open file anytime you have
a semi open file you really want your
rook there because it has a lot more
room to go obviously right now your rook
is worth five points but if it can't go
anywhere then what really good does it
do for your game so those are some of
the key concepts that you're going to be
looking at into the game obviously
White's trying to dominate and discern
the board trying to control development
trying to control the white squares the
light squares on the center of the board
blacks really trying to develop his
pieces from the outside kind of a hyper
modern defense and then later on he's
going to try to use this C file and try
to get some counter play on the Queen
side so we're going to go ahead and get
into it with the main line and that is
the yugoslavia tack now the Yugoslav
attack again this is the main line that
continues with Bishop to e3 again symbol
development move from white typically
his dark squared bishop is his least
valuable
bishop in the game black is going to now
play Bishop to g7 again black really
wanted to think it was bishop try to
control this long diagonal and then
White's going to play pawn to f3 now
right away from this pawn here on f3 we
know a couple things one is trying to
support this pawn here on e4 again this
pawn on e4 is a very very strong pawned
controlling the center of the board but
we also know that this pretty much means
that white is going to castle on the
Queen side typically if you do move your
F pawn and you castle on the King side
the typically is going to be coming to
the f4 square meaning you're trying to
eventually if it exchanges off you're
going to open up this file for your rook
FQ castle on the King side in this case
that's not what the goal of this pawn on
f3 is it's trying to support this pawn
here on e4 it's getting ready for later
pushes on the King side of black so
White's really not looking the castle on
the King side if he were he's pretty
much just making his pawn structure a
lot weaker and he's really not giving
his rook a lot of room to play around so
in this case F
we pretty much said that why it's going
to castle on the queenside now as you
can already imagine blacks next move is
going to castle on the kingside and
there's going to be a lot of fireworks
anytime both sides are going to castle
on different sides it's pretty much just
going to be a tactical crazy nightmare
and there's going to be just a lot of
aggressive play and if anyone slips up
it's pretty much going to be game over
so keep that in the back your head if
you're not real comfortable with crazy
and wild tactical games this might not
be too good for you the good thing I
like about the dragon variation from
black is across the board and the three
main lines that you'll see pretty much
it's the same moves over and over for
black it doesn't really matter which
variation white chooses - one which
we'll get into later but all the main
ones that you'll pretty much see day to
day black is going to pretty much move
the same thing so if you're sitting here
and you're like hey there's all these
variations in the dragon I don't really
remember all those that's okay because
you're going to be moving the same thing
you're going to be being kettering your
Bishop to g7 you're going to be
cancelling on the kingside you're going
to be bringing your knight to c6 going
to be bringing your Bishop to d7 it's
pretty much all going to be the same
from here also keep in mind this pawn
here on f3 is really blocking this
Knight coming to g4 instead of with this
Bishop communicating on the g7 square
black if you could would actually like
to come to g4 with his knight right away
again keep in mind that he does want to
bring his bishop to this dark Square and
control the long diagonal white later on
to the game really wants to exchange off
these dark squares so
if black in the situation can exchange
off his his Knight here on G for for the
bishop on e3 this is actually going to
be a good trade for black he can hold on
to his strong bishop in this game but if
you can see in this example if he plays
Knight to g4 before he can kiddos that's
going to be a huge mistake white can now
come and play Bishop to b5 doesn't
really matter how black plays he's going
to lose a piece if he plays Bishop to d7
it doesn't matter he can lose a piece
just with Queen takes on g4 or
if he takes excuse me if he moves his
Knight to d7 same thing doesn't really
matter he can move his queen
takes on g4 so he is definitely going to
lose material in this situation we'll go
ahead and continue with the main line so
we'll go ahead and back up here and
instead of bringing the Knight to g4
right away trying to attack this Bishop
here on e3 let's go in to continue in
fianchetto is Bishop to g7 White's now
going to play f3 so we're no longer even
thinking about bringing our Knight to g4
and we'll continue along Black's going
to castle on the King set from here
White's going to play Queen to d2 again
getting ready for his king to castle on
the Queen side and black is going to
play Knight to c6 now there are two
different variations from here that
white can play before I get into those I
do kind of want to stop again and kind
of look at some of the themes for both
sides on a chessboard right here now if
we kind of look at white why it's really
going to look to exchange off the dark
square Bishop Seguin the dark square
bishop is typically the weaker of the
bishops for white typically because the
light square bishop can attack the f7
squared which is a huge weakness for
black early on into the game especially
since it kind of holds down and pins
down to the King here on g8 so if black
has you know his way he really wants to
exchange off the light square bishop
from white so later on once the light
square bishop comes into the game if it
comes to c4 it becomes back to b3
doesn't really matter black is really
going to try to exchange off whether it
be with a knight whether it be with the
light square bishop he's going to try to
exchange off his lights for a bishop
because that's going to be a huge pain
in his side as it takes on this f7
square right here now also keep in mind
later on once this Bishop from c8 gets
involved into the game now the rook is
going to get involved is going to come
to the c8 squared is going to really try
to put a lot of pressure on this
semi-open file for the C file also keep
in mind that that White's really not
going to be moving his pawn here on a 2
B 2 or c2 obviously once he castles on
the Queen side it's going to be mu
his pawns it's going to be on the
kingside he's going to be thrusting
forward with moves like h4 he's going to
start getting his bishop involved into
the game he can start bringing his other
pawns involved into the game he's not
going to be wasting moves with a2 b2 c2
thrusting forward so if you do so you
see your opponent making moves like that
make them pay because again both sides
are going to be cancelling on different
sides so it's pretty much going to be
whoever can make their opponent fastest
so just keep these in mind when you're
thinking about this now again I did talk
about two different variations one of
the variations is to castle on the Queen
side right right away and the other is
to bring the Bishop to c4 attacking this
f7 Square right away now both of these
are going to take place in the
Yugoslavia Tackett just really depends
on which one you want to do first now
keep in mind if white decides to castle
on the Queen side black can always push
forward with d5 again with any opening
any time you're doing a hyper modern
defense basically trying to control the
center of the board with your minor
pieces from the outside eventually you
want to crack open and control the
center of the board you don't want your
opponent to control the turn the board
the entire game so once white castles on
the Queen side then black can play pawn
to d5 again trying to disrupt the center
of the board here now a lot of times
instead of castling on the Queen side
first you may instead see the bishop
come to c4 again this is now stopping
the pawn coming to d5 immediately and
it's also putting a lot of pressure on
this f7 squared now from here you may
see black develop his Bishop to d7 and
then from here you may see white castle
on the Queen side so as we talked about
before both of these moves are going to
happen it just is a matter of when you
want these moves to happen now from here
you could see black bring his rook to c8
again really trying to put a lot of
pressure on this C file now one thing he
does have to keep in mind is this route
this excuse me this night here on c6
will have to move typically you'll see
the variation continued with the bishop
coming back to b3 again he kind of wants
to make it safe
if this night were to come to a five he
could put a lot of pressure on it but
this Bishop here on b3 is still putting
a lot of pressure on this f7 square so
it doesn't really matter if he has it on
this c4 or this b3 squared simply does a
little bit better on the b3 squared
there's a kind of clog up the middle of
the board here from here the knight can
come to e5 again trying to control the
cylinder board more but at the same
token
he's also allowing for the the rook to
really hone down on this C file so these
are some of the key themes that you'll
see within the you Slav attack again
it's going to be very very aggressive on
both sides from white here white can
really try to start to attack on the the
King side he can start with moves like
h4 well I can try to stop that with pawn
to h5 if white wanted to he could bring
his bishop into the action and try to
trade off these dark squares as we
talked about before and then black is
going to try to counter on the Queen
side again he does have this semi-open C
file he can start to push these pawns
forward he can play let's say a six he
can start them with b5 he also has you
know his central knight here with E 5
this can kind of jump into the action
whatever he wants to he does have this
LightSquared bishop that can kind of
support these other pawns and pieces so
it's pretty much going to be chaos
pretty much why it's going to try to
control the king side and blacks going
to try to dominate on the Queen side so
this is the yugoslavia tack definitely
one of the main lines definitely want
more exciting lines if you ever have
played it it's pretty much just chaos
and sharp lines all over the place so
definitely recommend trying this out if
you really enjoy chess I think this will
really really piqued your interest now
the Lex the next line is the classical
variation it's for those white players
who come across the dragon variation
very very often but they really don't
want to get into the sharp tactical
lines the Yugoslavian too instead they
kind of like the positional play they
like the really solid openings and they
really like to play you know ABC chess
and so for those players we have the
classical variation and MIT from here
from the dragon defense we have Bishop
to e2 now as you can see this is very
different from the last defense the
Bishop before was coming to c4 after
white had canceled on the Queen side I
really tried to put a lot of pressure on
black on the King side now once he plays
Bishop to e2 he's no longer to looking
to play pawn to f3 which means y can
really think about castling on the Kings
side now it doesn't have to but that
option does you know playing Bishop to
e2 does give him this option so I see
many many people play the classical
variation and from here they will
actually castle on the King side now as
you can imagine if both sides castle on
the King side there's not going to be as
many fireworks so if you're playing is
white and you come across the dragon
variation you kind of want to slow
things down a little bit and kind of put
the speed bumps out there then they go
ahead just play Bishop to e2 don't go
ahead and play Bishop to e3 get into the
Yugoslavians that just play Bishop to e2
don't worry about pawn to f3 just kind
of do the quiet play now from here again
as I told you before Black's moves are
kind of the same so Black's going to
play Bishop to d7 being Quetta as Bishop
trying to do the same thing now the
bishop from from White's going to come
to e3 blacks now going to play Knight to
c6 again he's really trying to control
the center of the board all the moves
are again very very similar white canal
castle on the King side and black canal
castle on the Kings side as well so
again as you can see here this is more
of a positional play there's not going
to be as sharp of lines here going on
why it does have a few options he can
always bring his knight back to b3
really opening up this D file of his if
his queen wants to get involved into the
game he can always develop his queen and
then he can start to get his rooks
involved into the game if he wants to
really eye down on this D file um he
could also bring if he wanted to he
could bring his his knight over to b5
again typically more times than not
you're going to see the knight come back
to b3 it's actually a very very good
square for the
night to come back to now from blacks
point of view he's kind of trying to do
the same thing he's trying to control
the dark squares on the center of the
board he's looking to get his light
square Bishop involved into the game he
does have a few more options now he
could always now bring his Bishop to e6
he's not too worried about the bishop
coming to c4 is that what kind of b2
moves for the lights her Bishop from
white in the opening you typically don't
see someone moving there they're minor
pieces over and over again if they don't
have to also the rook can come to c8 he
can try to control the semi open file on
the C file so a lot of different things
going on in this variation in the
classical variation but it all kind of
stems from from the same idea that we
talked about in the Yugoslavia tech but
this is the classical variation now the
next variation we're going to be talking
about is my favorite variation it's the
Lebanon fish variation it's actually
more aggressive from white so if you're
playing white and you start out with
efore and black tries to you know
counter that with the dragon variation
basically saying hey I'm ready to go
let's do this thing you can respond with
11 fish variation which basically says
hey I want to be even more aggressive
than you are right now and that actually
is pawn to f4 you can kind of tell right
away that fireworks are going to ensue
and what this pretty much does is it
kind of starts the fireworks as far as
the the pawn thrusting forward right
away typically in the Yugoslavia TAC
even in the classical variation doesn't
really matter which side you know you're
going to be castling on typically
there's going to be a lot of pawns being
pushed forward typically in the
Yugoslavia TAC once the Queen's castle
down the the Kings castles on the Queen
side all the pieces are developed then
why it starts to really push forward
with the pawns the lemon fish variation
pretty much says hey we're going to push
forward right away with pawn to f4
really eyeing down with this pawn to e5
really trying to control the center of
the board here now this is the one
variation that talked about where black
has to change things up as we talk as
we'll talk about here in a minute if he
plays Bishop to g7 this is actually
going to be a big mistake from black
which is why I like to play
this from whites point of view so yes we
are going over all the variations from
you know the dragon but I do also want
to give a shout out to the players that
are playing white you may come across
this many times so even if you don't
want to play this as black if you are
white and you do see this you may want
to throw the 11 fish variation if you
are very aggressive because a lot of
times again as we talked about before
people that play the dragon are so used
to playing the same moves over and over
they're so used to being ketamine their
bishop then bringing their Knight to c6
then castling on the Kings side they
pretty much don't know anything
different but in this case they actually
do want to bring their knight to c6
before they think either their Bishop to
g7 I'll show you why here in a minute
but pretty much they want to stop this
thrusting forward of pawn to e5 if we
exchange right here then the knight can
take on e5 but if this Knights not here
it's going to be a lot of problems going
forward so that's kind of what I want to
talk about right now if the bishop comes
to g7 black is going to have huge
problem from here white can play Bishop
to b5 very very strong move black does
have a lot of different option I kind of
want to go over the main ones it's
really not going to do a lot of good to
bring his knight to c6 again he will
lose material doesn't really matter how
we we kind of slice that up here he is
going to lose material we can even you
know if we wanted to exchange with our
knight here first and then he's going to
check the King here and attack this rook
here on a 8 so that's not really good
move his other options would Bree would
be to bring a piece to this d7 square so
we'll kind of look at some of those
options right here
his first two options he does is to
bring either the bishop or the knight
here to d7 so we'll go ahead and start
with the knight here coming to d7 now
from here again as we talked about
before why it's going to push forward
he's going to play pawn to e5 and starts
to put a lot of pressure on this night
here on f6 now it doesn't really matter
if black exchanges or not pretty much
going to do the same thing we'll go
ahead and take a look at it if he does
exchange will say that the pawn takes on
e5 White's going to respond taking and
now
the Black Knight has to move obviously
he can't take with his night here from
d7 because he's being pinned down from
this bishop here on b5 so he has to move
he can either come back to g8 or he can
move over to h5 doesn't really matter
we'll just put them here on h5 and then
the pawns going to continue down the
board putting a lot of pressure on black
with pawn to e6 now the really only way
that black has to save face here as far
as a material standpoint is to play pawn
takes on e6
after he does that black or excuse me
white can now come in with Knight
capturing on e6 you can start to see
blacks really starting to fall apart as
far as his structure his Kings no longer
safe doesn't really matter if he castles
on the King side or the Queen side he's
not going to be safe at all you never
want a piano here Bishop on the King
side and then lose your F pawn this is
this is definitely not the way you want
to go obviously the King here on a1 he
can castle on the Kings side make his
rook here on the F file very very
powerful it's a full open file where you
can always castle on the Queen side he
does have a lot of safety here on the
Queen side so it doesn't really matter
how you look at it blacks going to be in
a lot of trouble now again we can come
back here we can you know let's say he
doesn't move his pawn here he can always
move his knight back to g8 right away it
doesn't really matter White's going to
continue with the same thing as we
talked about he can bring his pawn to e6
now again putting a lot of pressure on
this pawn on f7 again he's also
attacking this night here on d7 which
cannot move so again the only thing he
can do is bring his knight excuse me his
pawn to e6 and after he recaptures the
game we're kind of in the same boat
right here putting a lot of pressure on
black and there's not a lot for him to
do same thing is really going to happen
if he brings his Bishop to d7 we're
going to continue doing the same thing
pushing forward with our pawns pawn to
e5 again if he captured doesn't really
matter he's going to take Knights going
to have to move and then we continue to
push forward with the pawn here on e6 if
he takes he's still going to be in a lot
of trouble do want to touch on one other
point probably one of his better moves
he does has is
he brings his knight back to d7 from
here White has a few options but again
is if you kind of look at it White's
really putting a lot of pressure on
black and blacks really stopping a lot
of his development possibilities yes he
is kind of saving face a little bit as
far as a material standpoint but he no
longer King in his light squared bishop
involved into the game he can castle on
the Kings side but he's pretty much
moved his minor piece his night here on
f6
he's now moved it to d7 which is not you
really don't want to be moving your
minor pieces all over the board also as
we can tell you know white doesn't have
a lot of different options from here he
can castle on the King side really start
to put a lot of pressure again he still
has this pawn on f4 so he can start to
push that forward put a lot of pressure
he can always get his Queen involved
into the game he this dark script bishop
involved into the game it's going to be
very hard for black to put a lot of
pressure on white right now in other
radiations we have a lot of tactical you
know and aggressive lines from black but
right now is just kind of being passive
kind of just blocking everything that
white has and why it's kind of just
starting to really dominate this here in
the board as far as development it's
going to be really hard for black in
this situation so again the Levin fish
variation just starts with that pawn to
f4 very very aggressive line from white
but I find it very very useful
especially for those players that are
not too familiar with it now the last
variation is the Harrington neglect
variation and there's not as much theory
on it so I'm not going to go too in
depth in it just because you don't see
it that often at all but but definitely
knowing that the concepts that we've
talked about in the video you may want
to try it out it does have some great
positional play from white side again
blacks theories kind of the same he's
going to be playing the same moves from
the beginning but it starts out with
Bishop to e3 from white blacks good do
continue the same thing with Fein
ketamine's Bishop to g7 excuse me that
the pot the bishop is now going to come
to e2
Black's going to castle on the kingside
and then the queen is going to come to
d2 from here blacks going to continue
with Knight to c6 again same format we
talked about before and then White has
two options he can castle on the King
side or you can castle on the Queen side
so if you're looking for a lot of you
know a lot of different ideas as far as
which way you can you can go you can
kind of mix it up you can try some games
castle on the Kings side you can move I
have some games castle on the Queen side
more times than not you're going to see
castling on the Queen side again you
kind of do have all your pieces kind of
lined up against the King side so you
kind of have an attack already starting
again from here white really wants to
start pushing forward with his pawns on
the King side he does start to have you
know his bishop his bishops and his
knights ready to go attacking on the
King side so not as sharp as players
we've seen from some of the other moves
you know the Yugoslavia TAC where you
know the bishops coming out to see for
putting a lot of pressure on black on
the f7 square but but you definitely
still see a lot of solid play from white
so it really depends on how aggressive
or not aggressive you want to be in this
defense from both sides from black or
from white you have a ton of different
options there's so much theory so many
fantastic games that you can watch if
you kind of like one of the variations
if you say you know what you know I
really liked 11 fish variation go check
out some some different games of some of
the famous players that have played that
if you kind of like the Yugoslavia nice
games play by that there there's so much
great theory based on all these and kind
of think about some of the themes and
the ideas that we talked about and kind
of see how those players use you know
the semi open file for the rook here see
how white really tries to control the
center of the board with the light
squares see how you know white really
tries to you know exchange his dark
squared bishop off the board and how
black really tries to exchange the light
square bishop off from from e2 so really
don't just try to memorize all the moves
that we talked about as we get into the
series of going
into the different lines really just
start to pay attention to all the the
theory and the key concepts that we're
talking about in the videos so again
this is this is video number one hope
you guys enjoy the video of some deeper
analysis of some of the variations that
you'll see in some of the more common
openings like the Sicilian defense if
you have requests definitely let me know
again I have a huge list of videos that
I do want to make but again upon request
I def I definitely will move those up
and down depending on you know how
people are requesting those so hopefully
you guys enjoy the dragon variation in
the Sicilian defense definitely leave
some calm some feedback let me know what
you guys think and I'll see you guys in
the next video thanks for watching